Speaker 1: I want to start today with something
many of you have been writing to me about,
and it's the question essentially, if Joe
Biden doesn't run for reelection, do Democrats
have any good candidates for 2024, particularly
to run against Donald Trump if he's the nominee
or Ron DeSantis, if he's the nominee?
Now, why are we contextualizing this with
Trump and DeSantis?
Well?
Because they're the only two pool polling
anything even remotely viable in every CPAC
straw poll and Republican opinion poll.
It's Trump leading.
And then Ron DeSantis with between 10 and
22 percent, depending on the poll or straw
poll that you look at.
Everybody else is in the low single digits.
So at least for now, let's theorize that it
will be or is likely to be Donald Trump or
Ron DeSantis in 2024.
Now, I've already said before, it's unclear
if Joe Biden is going to run for reelection.
The language being used by the White House
is very narrow.
When Jen Psaki is asked questions like if
Joe Biden plans to run, why hasn't he announced
or filed or whatever, and she'll say Joe Biden
has the intention of running for reelection,
which is a very specifically worded phrase.
I think they just don't know if Joe Biden
is going to run for reelection or they may
know he's not going to.
And then the question becomes, well, well,
so then what?
And much of this is wrapped up with how the
midterm elections go.
Much of this connects to the continued and
obvious efforts that the right is going to
make to take the election, whether they win
it or not.
And unfortunately, it's not looking very good.
I think it would be an obvious lie if I said
to you, there's a great bullpen right now,
there is all sorts of great people.
First of all, if Biden does run for reelection
against Trump, I don't see that going well
for Biden.
And I've explained before that one of the
reasons for that is so far Biden's presidency.
Although there is no doubt that there have
been a number of tangible successes which
I outlined last week, maybe the week before.
It has not been an interesting presidency
in the sense of inspiring people.
Joe Biden's approval has been trickling down,
and it seems to me that Donald Trump, if than
if he was the nominee against Joe Biden, would
be able to sort of reinvigorate a lot of the
same people on whose vote he won in 2016.
I don't see that going particularly well.
I am unsure about Biden versus DeSantis, but
unfortunately, DeSantis is almost like a more
competent Trump, which can be very dangerous.
So then the immediate conversation becomes,
if not Biden.
What about Kamala Harris?
It would be natural in some sense that there
would sort of be a primary, but really that
if it's not Biden, the DNC would kind of anoint
Kamala Harris as the de facto nominee.
That seems very problematic.
Kamala Harris is current approval or favorability
is 39 percent, and that's lower than every
recent vice president and some by a lot at
this point in time.
This was taken at day 378.
Mike Pence was more popular and more liked
than Kamala Harris.
Joe Biden was more popular and more liked
As Vice President, Dick Cheney was significantly
more favorable, favorably seen than Kamala
Harris, and Al Gore was dramatically more
favorably seen than Kamala Harris.
So the numbers don't look great for Kamala
Harris right now.
It looks like a very uphill battle if it's
going to be Harris versus Trump or Harris
versus Ron DeSantis, so that doesn't look
good.
Then there was this idea of bring Hillary
Clinton back.
Now I already talked about why.
I think that's not a good idea.
I think it can't possibly go well, and there
are a number of different reasons.
One is that Hillary Clinton never really inspired
the type of energy that I think is necessary,
particularly running against a reinvigorated
Trumpian electorate.
And even if it's DeSantis, it will still be
a Trumpian electorate.
DeSantis is a sort of Trump, although now
they are publicly feuding.
Trump and DeSantis are.
The electorate is quite similar.
So then you've got the people saying, Well,
Bernie, Bernie is the guy.
It's finally Bernie's time.
I'm not going to blow smoke anywhere.
To me, Bernie's time is done.
Bernie ran twice.
He would be 83 at the time of inauguration.
If the idea is that there needs to be more
energy than Biden, although I agree that Bernie
has more energy than Biden, it's not seeming
to me.
Like the guy who already lost twice is going
to be the guy who at 83 is going to come in
and, you know, blow the top off the electorate
and defeat Trump or DeSantis.
If you have evidence and data that suggests
it could be Bernie.
Let me know.
I'm willing to be told I'm wrong, but it's
not seeming great.
Then you've got the AOC crowd.
People say AOC, AOC has the energy.
She has the likability.
That's true.
AOC has a lot of energy.
AOC would be old enough to be president by
two months, roughly two and a half months,
something like that at the time of the next
inauguration.
It's not seeming plausible to me that 34 year
old AOC successfully runs on the basis that
I'll be old enough by two months on Inauguration
Day.
That doesn't seem to me like the recipe for
a success.
I'm just being realistic with you.
I read something about Amy Klobuchar.
Tons of people hate Amy Klobuchar.
She never polled more than six in 2020.
But I have to tell you, Klobuchar, to me,
sounds less crazy than Harris or Hillary in
the context of 2024.
Now, Perry Bacon Jr. wrote a piece in The
Washington Post talking about, among other
people, Kentucky Gov. Andy Beshear, a white
male Democrat but from the South and the governor,
rather than a senator, which sometimes can
be more appealing to people in different parts
of the country, the South, the Midwest, etc.
It's an interesting idea.
I don't know much about Andy Beshear, so I'll
sort of put a pin in that, but that's something
Perry Bacon Jr. wrote about.
Now, Perry Bacon Jr. also writes about Tim
Kaine, who ran alongside Hillary in 2016.
It is difficult to imagine a less exciting
and more milquetoast candidate than Tim Kaine.
I feel almost embarrassed to even mention
the idea of Tim Kaine as the nominee.
It's it's very tough to imagine that's the
direction, so I don't see any strong candidates
right now.
A few things I will mention on rhetoric, and
what I mean by that is in terms of being able
to mix it up with people effectively in media
and in debates and come up with sort of like
snappy comebacks and optics.
There's something interesting about Pete Buttigieg,
but he's already suffered and been the target
of significant character assassination in
his role as secretary of Department of Transportation,
Secretary of Transportation.
You don't typically see that Secretary of
Transportation into presidential candidate.
It's unclear what his fate would be.
So I'm just not sure about it.
And then it has to be said that on policy.
Elizabeth Warren is one of the most left candidates
of anybody who's recently run other than Bernie.
Her wealth tax proposal is something to the
left of what most Democratic candidates have
proposed.
But on a personality personality level, the
country really does not seem to like Elizabeth
Warren, so that doesn't seem particularly
good either.
So it's a very tough situation.
Let's get through the midterms insofar as
what happens will inform what the dynamics
of 2024 might be.
But I am not particularly optimistic about
the farm team right now.
I'm open to having my mind changed.
Let me
know
what
you think this this is.